après avoir été volé à dijon la berline
terminera sa route sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de lyon le forcené lui finira
sa course folle à pied qui est cet
agresseur selon le parquet de dijon
il s'agit d'un homme de 31 ans habitant
le quartier des grésillés
il est sans antécédent judiciaire le
vice-procureur dijonnais jean luc chemin
indique que lors de l'agression à la
station service
l'homme aurait agi seul sans aucune
complicité le parquet de dijon s'est
dessaisi de l'affairé au profit de lyon
celui ci ayant ouvert une enquête pour
les faits les plus graves commis sur
l'aéroport de saint-exupéry
hier le procureur lyonnais de la
république se montraient très prudents
quant au profil de l'agresseur
tant que les services enquêteurs des
services du parquet n'ont pas fait les
vérifications
je préfère pas me livrer à vous
communiquer des éléments d'information
sur ce passé policiers ou judiciaires ou
aux psychiatres hic parce que c'est
aussi une possibilité qui méritera dans
les heures qui viennent d'être
exactement circonscrit aujourd'hui selon
la lfp l'homme de 31 ans a été
hospitalisé d'office
une expertise psychiatrique a conclu que
son état n'était pas compatible avec la
garde à vue
point important le suspect n'est pas
signalés pour radicalisation le parquet
antiterroriste de paris ne s'est pas
saisie de la faire